hey everyone Anthony Bouchon developer
relations engineer here today I'm
excited to talk about how you can better
protect the resources in your gke
clusters using backup for gke Google's
fully managed and configurable backup
and restore service so let's dive into
it
now one thing users love about
kubernetes and gke right out of the gate
is the resiliency that their workloads
get by default kubernetes controllers
ensure that workloads are constantly
driven to your desired state for them
even in the face of Transit failures
with that said sometimes changes might
be made to a workload configuration and
error or users just require additional
protection against workload data that
isn't accounted for by kubernetes alone
with critical recovery Point objectives
some users may not be satisfied by this
default Behavior
CDs users may want to perform
point-in-time backups of kubernetes
resources and their workload data in
their cluster and then have the control
to choose what to restore and where to
restore from these backups
this helps them minimize data loss in
case of things like user error
application failure disaster and helps
them meet their recovery objectives so
enter backup for gke a fully managed
solution to automate the backup and
restore lifecycle for gke users backup
for gke can perform backup and point in
time restore operations for users across
two dimensions
first is the backup of kubernetes
configuration for resources running in
your cluster the actual yaml itself
we can think of this as the state of the
cluster both cluster and namespace scope
resources that are persisted in the
kubernetes control plane
second is the backup of data residing in
persistent volumes utilized by workloads
we can think of this as the state that
is owned by the workload like stateful
workloads that mount volumes and write
data to these volumes with backup for
gke you can backup all cluster and
namespace resources in your cluster
while also backing up stateful data in
persistent volumes and if you want you
can perform more granular backups for a
set of selected namespaces in your
cluster
you see each individual backup that you
perform using backup for gke takes its
shape from a backup plan that you create
which defines the scope of your backups
these individual backups from a backup
plan can be scheduled to run on a
regular Cadence or can be performed
manually ad hoc
and when the time comes to perform a
restore each of these individual
restorers will reference a restore plan
which defines what backup plan to use
and what resources to restore when
restoring to a cluster
restores themselves can also be granular
restoring either an entire backup or
just a subset of a backup and given that
backup for gke is its own fully managed
cloud service you can also use IAM to
restrict who can administer and perform
these backups and restores with backup
for gke so many patterns to meet
different recovery objectives are
possible for instance you can backup all
resources and data in one cluster and
restore all of them to a different
cluster in the event of a disaster
you can also back up all resources in a
cluster and only restore a specific
namespace to the same cluster with its
respective workloads and their volume
data and to get started you can enable
backup for gke on an existing gke
cluster without any changes to your
kubernetes resource definitions but what
if you wanted more specific logic
orchestrating backups or a set of
components backup for gke has something
for that too you can create a custom
resource called a protected application
this can group together specific
resources within a namespace that you
want to backup and restore
this custom resource can also carry out
additional logic specific to your
application with its support for pre and
post backup scripts to learn more and
get started with backup for gke check
out the links in the description and as
always thank you for your time
[Music]